God we thank you for an opportunity to
speak about the hearts of those who
sometimes cannot fight for themselves
thank you for this moment to be able to
share our hearts with the president and
his administration dr. King said we
cannot influence a table that we are not
seated in and so we pray that this
conversation will be fruitful and
productive and honoring of the best
traditions of this nation how many times
did you see former presidents praying
like that and they I love that moment
that was President Trump on Wednesday he
held a meeting with inner-city religious
leaders where several of the pastors
expressed support for President Trump's
policies especially this new push for
prison and sentencing reform well that
actually did not go over well with some
congregants of these pastors who say
Trump has not been good for the black
community despite a record-low
unemployment rate joining me now are two
pastors who attended that event pastor
Daryl Scott founder of the new spirit
revival Center in Cleveland Heights Ohio
and pastor Van moody of the Worship
Center Christian Church in Birmingham
Alabama
along with Democratic strategist Antoine
C right from New York it's great to have
all of you on tonight let's start with
you pastor van Moody you received some
blowback after being at the White House
on Wednesday tell us about that well yes
I did receive tremendous amount of
blowback a lot of vitriol a lot of
name-calling a number of individuals
that have been a part of a number of
things that I've done books that I've
written conferences and other ministry
opportunities have said that they're
leaving and many people expressed a lot
of anger and frustration because I was
there but also because one of the
comments that I made I think was
misunderstood and taken out of context
when I thanked President Trump for him
having a heart for people as it relates
to this issue of prison reform and
workforce development so it's been quite
a challenge but once again I think the
purpose of trying to make a difference
in the lives of people that are
marginalized and voiceless is some
bigger van personal attack and political
ideology and that's why I went in the
first place
well how ironic that we have a president
who seems very open to taking on this
very complicated issue of prison reform
ending this scourge of recidivism we're
in federal prisons about 76 percent of
the current federal prison population
have already served time they they want
to put an end to that so people can
rejoin it communities get jobs you know
be retrained having to have a job skill
and it's a it's a big and heavy lift but
I think they're gonna get this done and
it would it takes everybody to do this
and you know pastor Scott I'd like you
to chime in here because I think it's so
brave that Pastor Van moody came to the
White House I can't believe I have to
describe it as brave but it is brave in
this society that we live in today
that's a I mean he took a bold step and
I commend and applaud him and the other
pastors my other colleagues for coming
as well but listen it's time to put
those identity politics aside put this
pettiness aside try to suppress this
black-white divide that the left is
trying to promulgate in this country and
sit down and have some meaningful
productive dialogue that can lead to
some meaningful productive change in
this country the president has a heart
for prison reform I've been working with
him on this for over a year the
president Jared Kushner criminal justice
reform is another issue that is one the
president's heart that he has a concern
about and we've had many different
discussions concerning this and urban
revitalization I'm working with him on
the urban revitalization issues we're
going to endeavor to have the most
ambitious public-private partnership
regarding urban revitalization in
American history I said it at the
meeting people took me to task I said
this is going to be this president Trump
has the potential to be the most Pro
black president in my lifetime because
all of the presidents not lived under 12
different presidents he's the 12th one
the prior eleven were all reactive
towards the black
even our great icons Johnson and and
Kennedy that they say are holding up the
Civil Rights icons they were reactive
towards social upheaval President Trump
is being proactive towards the black
communities get anti suing these things
that's great
let's get Antoine's response you heard
what the pastor just said Trump could be
the most Pro black president in modern
history
yes something does I think that's
disappointing and keep in mind I'm not a
pastor but I grew up I'm a
fourth-generation AME I grew up in the
church I know a little bit about
leadership my uncle's at the 130 333
elected Amy Bishop and AME Church and
what I do know is that when they passed
their steps out of the pulpit or in the
pulpit they represent the hearts and
minds of the entire congregation and
what we know about this president from
the time before he when he was running
for president up until now he has not
had the best interest of
african-americans if you look at his
rhetoric if you look at some of the
things his administration has done if
you look at some of the taking whether
it's whether it's voter suppression
whether it's mandatory
absolutely talking about [ __ ]
countries whether he's called Mexicans
rapists and thugs if you look at and he
campaigned on it yeah he wanted to undo
everything Barack Obama had done I'm
clearly articulating why I disagree with
these paths yes your bumper sticker
mentality Pastor Moody go ahead yeah I
think one of the things that people have
to understand is for me as a faith
leader I'm called to something much
higher than politics and egos and
ideology and for me this was very simple
there are a number of individuals that
are voiceless and disenfranchised in the
prison population African Americans for
an example make up 12 to 13 percent of
the American population but nearly 35
percent of the prison population and so
for me it's not a left issue it's not a
right issue it is how can we help issue
and how can we continue to model the
ethic of Jesus Christ and it is not
about saying exactly but it is not about
if we're going to do this we've got to
set aside petty politics we've got to
put our egos aside and we've also got to
be able to find commonality between this
issue of what you like and what I don't
like I believe that even if but wait a
second and I talked about in my op-ed
piece I've been on record of voicing
some issues that I've had with this
administration but I still believe that
we ought to be able to find commonality
to work for the good of other people we
have got to move beyond who we like who
we don't like because there are lives
that are we don't like or do like what
this is about is working in a bipartisan
way if we really want to do it to get
something okay
what I find and this is interesting
because I hear this on my radio show all
the time I learn more by listening to
people who are not in politics and not
pundits like myself I learned more from
listening to other people people have
faith people in business that I do from
people who are in that narrow lane of
politics because you're living from the
real life so the faith and Angelus like
say that's not the real life Laura I'm
not trying to put down what you say I'm
just saying sometimes when you take it
out of politics and you and you and you
give it over to a higher power good
things can happen not always but good
things can happen and I will now allow a
pastor Scott to speak listen gentlemen
such as Anton whatever your name
these guys - I see right I was
respectful to you I didn't know your
name so I said whatever it is
he noted listen you guys were rather
this country failed then Trump succeed
you gotta being bipartisan you okay you
then I put it on you you're talking
about a Donald Trump personally you were
rather the country fail then work
together for Donald Trump to succeed
we're sitting there talking to my prison
reform to help prisoners and you're
upset that people weren't in the room
without time but we're gonna be covering
prison reform for I mean I think a
couple of months at least and it looks
like we're gonna actually accomplish
something we're gonna be bringing you
back great segment thank you so much